[Music]
has it clued in do you understand the
history you made tonight
you know what I do I do I think I'm very
aware of how important this win was good
it's not just about me it's about all
these amazing women of color who are
phenomenal writers people like Gina
first by the whispers of the Hilmar buck
Akhil
Yvette Lee Bowser people like Shonda
wrong I mean they've opened up doors for
me so if I can crack open the door at
all for women of color I mean it's just
an honor to do that it's not lost on me
at all they call your name and what goes
through your mind uh okay now I got to
make sure I don't get played off that
was my biggest fear I was like I gotta
say something to seize it he already
told me like if we get ugly Wayne you're
gonna talk you called me this morning he
said just don't forget the thing Netflix
I was like okay but I was extremely
nervous like my girlfriend is over there
she was like trying to breathe try to
breathe try to breathe but the biggest
thing for me I want to speak from the
heart
you know yeah what is it like working
with disease and what does it mean to
work on his show and also then the fact
that he says you guys aren't gonna rush
your content out yeah I feel like he's
like a colleague but a mentor as well
he's very thoughtful he's very you know
purposeful and his thing is with this
work he doesn't want to rush it he knows
it's like we've got to live life and
really breathing take our time before we
put out content you know we've been very
blessed with our first second season we
have an audience that trusts us so we
don't want to just give them something
rush so we hope that if and when we come
back for Season we give them something
just a special magic and if I don't know
if I don't know Mariner called Netflix
right now hold that up you better hold
that up or Netflix to tell them look man
look it's up to Aziz man it's like
whatever he calls I'm gonna come running
yay and that's the one thing I want to
ask you is he ready to make more you
know I think he's chilling right now I
think he's chilling I think he's living
life you know he's got it he's got a
refill before we go back out there okay
I get that what do you do tonight and
where does this let me go what do I do
tonight tonight you know celebrate
tonight
I'm with my cool I literally got I think
the most you know I asked like a plus
nine for the network's party because it
was like even if I lost I was like we
still gonna celebrate right but at once
through the belle of the ball tonight
you understand you come in like hey hey
you know Chuck Jimmy Fox it up like
anyone asking permission but no I'm
definitely celebrate we don't get it in
I don't know where it's gonna go with
the crib it's probably a dining room
table for awhile until we figure out a
space for it yeah I just carried it for
Elwyn which makes sense makes it I
thought I'm gonna do that huge night
thank you huge night thank you gradual
enjoy watching so much yes really
I'm a fan of your work is what you guys
do on that show it's real it comes
across as real
that's the biggest compliment go enjoy
this party I will
[Music]
you